it's a sightly white never gets used to
its the sight and smell of failure and
even from the air the stench of elephant
death is everywhere the poachers have
left the carcass to the maggots to
finish off this festering Hulk was once
one of Gabon's male forest elephants a
subspecies with pinkish ivory which is
very hard and which makes them very
attractive to the ivory poachers and the
ivory is most likely already out of
Gabon and enroute to China it's one we
didn't protect
Lee he obviously seen this many more
times than you care to mention does it
get any less upsetting no it gets worse
you just have to yeah never wait on your
heart every time you see it but you see
it more and more and more I guess we
can't afford to get numb to it because
then we'd stop caring DNA is taken the
Royal Zoological Society in Edinburgh is
helping set up the first DNA
fingerprinting for Elephants which could
match blood with tusks sees thousands of
miles away in say China or Vietnam but
there's an air of hopelessness here I
think we probably I'm going to to find
out to solve many cases but if we can
solve one two or three it's like an
example the increasingly desperate fight
to stop the slaughter of the African
elephant has the backing of Gabbana's
president his country has lost a third
of its elephant population in the past
decade he took us for a walk in the rain
forest which is second only to the
Amazon in size and was full of tough
talk about China and what he expects
from the London conference what do you
want them to do specifically what will
you be asking them to do the same as we
are doing no zero tolerance
we want them to have the towards the
elephant or the her idol the same
attitude that they have to know
regarding panda I don't think that they
would appreciate us going into China
killing pandas for any kind of reason
they will certainly take action well
we're just telling them you know we feel
the same about our elephants and her
rhinos as you do with pandas
look closely because this is an
increasingly rare sight and one the next
generation may never see unless actions
taken now but the profits from killing
just one of these creatures are so big
that criminal gangs and terrorist
organizations have already pushed this
animal to the brink of extinction
Alex Crawford Sky News Gabon